If you've ever installed a wireless
router or any type of small office home
office device, you'll notice that it has
a default username and a default
password. These defaults are necessary
so that you can log to the device the
first time, but you should be sure to
change those passwords after your first
login. These devices usually have a
single login and that login has
administrative access to the entire
device. If someone does have access to
this device and the default login is
still active, they will effectively have
full control. And even if someone
doesn't know the default login, this
information is very easy to find on the
internet. There's a website
routerpass.com
that lists out all of these device
models, their default username and their
default password.
Many of these all-in-one SOHO devices
often have a number of security
features. For example, you might be able
to do content filtering or IP address
filtering on the device. You usually
have the option of setting an allow list
so that nothing passes through the
firewall except the things that you
specify. This is obviously the most
restrictive of the settings because
every IP address or website you'd like
to visit needs to be added to the
firewall. A more common implementation
would be the deny list where you're
allowed to visit any site you'd like
except for the ones that are
specifically listed in the security
policies. So there might be a list of
URLs or IP addresses that you cannot
visit, but everything else on the
internet is effectively available.
These appliances that we install into
our home office or small office have an
operating system that also has to be
maintained. This operating system is
referred to as the firmware of this
device. And this firmware is usually
proprietary and comes directly from the
manufacturer. These updates don't
usually have the same frequency as
something like Microsoft Windows. But
any updates that get pushed out might
have bug fixes, new features, or
security patches. Just like your laptops
and mobile phones, you'll also want to
make sure that all of your SOHO
appliances are up to date with the
latest version of firmware. So, make
sure that your update processes include
these devices, whether they are a
router, a firewall, a switch, or any
other device that you might be using.
Content filtering is a very good way to
restrict what people can see in their
browser. This is usually filtering
information based on a specific URL or
it's based on a broad category of URLs
that you might visit. For example, your
content filtering might have a single
URL that's pointing to a well-known
gambling site. Or you could set a broad
website category that says, "Deny all
access to any website that is
categorized as gambling." This is also a
way that you can control the transfer of
sensitive data in and out of your
network. So, you might want to set a
content filter that restricts access to
any of the file sharing websites that
people commonly visit. We also see this
being used to prevent things that are
inappropriate from showing up on your
screen at work. So, if it's not for
professional use, then you'll probably
see it restricted in your content
filtering security policy. And some
content filters may allow you to visit a
site, but they will scan all of the
incoming data to make sure that no
viruses or malware are allowed inside of
your network.
In a small office home office
environment, there's usually a single
device that has multiple features. So it
might be a router, a wireless access
point, a switch, a content filter, and a
firewall all in one device. Usually that
one device is located somewhere close to
the connection coming in from the
internet service provider. In a small
office, you might have multiple devices,
a number of servers, and other pieces of
equipment. So all of that equipment
might be stored behind a locked door or
in a secure room. If you have a single
wireless access point, having that
device where your internet service
provider line comes in may not be the
most convenient location. For access
points, you'd like to get them high in
the air and in a central location so
that everybody has equal access to that
signal. You also have to think about how
you might have to reboot that device.
So, if this is something that has to be
managed directly on the box, you may not
want to put it too high out of reach. If
you are able to plan out where this will
go and you're able to run the
appropriate cables, you might be able to
install it in a central location where
everybody has easy access to the
wireless network.
One of the challenges with these small
office or home office devices is there's
not usually an IT technician who's
available to do any type of
configurations. This is why UPN was
created. This is universal
plug-and-play. This is a feature built
into these small office routers that
allows them to be configured using
software that you're running as an
application. This means we don't have to
log into the router and make
configuration changes. We simply start
an application on our local internal
network. That application will
communicate with your router and using
universal plug-and-play. It will make
configuration changes to your router to
allow inbound traffic to that
application. From a security
perspective, universal plug-and-play is
usually not turned on because you don't
want to have an application able to make
configuration changes to inbound traffic
on your router. This could cause
significant security problems. So, it's
very common to disable universal
plug-and-play on all of these devices.
Some firewalls will support a
configuration that includes a screened
subnet. You might have heard of this
referred to as a demilitarized zone or
DMZ. This is a network that you would
connect to your firewall that's not part
of your internal network where all of
your private company information is.
It's a completely separate subnet that
is specifically designed for inbound
traffic to your local services. So now
you have this protected screen subnet
where you can keep all of these publicly
facing services but still maintain an
internal network that still has high
security. For example, your local
network might have a web server that's
providing services for people on the
internet, and you would put that web
server into the screen subnet. Your
internal network would still be
available to support all of your local
systems and keep all of your company
data private.
These small office and home office
routers become very important devices.
Once you log in, you effectively have
full control over what data is able to
go from one network to another. For that
reason, it's important to tightly
control who has access to that device.
You've certainly changed the default
login for this device, but you also want
to make sure that the password that
you're using is a strong password. And
if you're able to add additional
multiffactor authentication, that would
also provide additional security. Some
devices also allow you to log in to a
cloud-based service, which then grants
you access to manage this device
remotely. And some of these devices
provide additional security controls by
IP address. So you can define what IP
addresses are able to connect to this
device and log in to the management
front end. As another best practice, you
may want to make sure that any type of
remote management is disabled so that no
one is able to log into this device from
across the internet. You must be on your
local network to be able to log in to
the management front end of this device.
One thing that you might see often is a
wireless network popping up in your list
that has the default name of that
particular device. For example, you
might see a link wireless network or a
Netgear wireless network. This name that
we see in our list of available wireless
networks is referred to as an SSID. It
stands for a service set identifier and
it effectively is the name that we are
associating with this wireless network.
A good best practice would be to change
the SSID from the default to something
that is either not quite as obvious or
might have more of a connection with
your organization. And if you wanted to
remove that wireless network from the
pull down list, you could disable the
SSID broadcast. There's probably a
configuration option within your
wireless device that allows you to
enable and disable the SSID broadcast.
This is not a security control because
it doesn't prevent somebody from
connecting to the network if they happen
to know the name, but it does prevent
the name from showing up in a list of
other wireless networks. So, this would
be more for an administrative function
than it would be for a security
function. Sometimes you'll hear this
referred to as security through
obscurity. By making this process more
obscure, you're trying to make the
process more secure. In reality, of
course, security through obscurity is in
reality not security at all. There are a
number of different ways to provide
authentication access to these wireless
networks. One of them is to simply have
an open network. There's no
authentication password needed and
anyone who is nearby can connect to that
wireless network. This is the type of
network that you might see if you're at
a coffee shop or you've checked into a
hotel. A more secure network might
provide encryption and require you to
provide additional credentials to
connect to the wireless network. You can
do this by using WPA2 or WPA3 for your
encryption. And there is a method called
a personal or PSK configuration that you
might want to consider using. This is
the type of configuration you often see
in a home office because the PSK is a
pre-shared key. It's effectively a
password that you give out to everyone
who wants to access the wireless
network. On an enterprise network,
however, you would prefer that everyone
use a separate username and password to
gain access to the wireless network. And
those credentials are often centralized
on a directory service. You might see
this configuration called WPA2 or WPA3
enterprise or 802.1x.
And if you are in an area with a lot of
different access points, it might be
difficult to find an available
frequency. Many access points will
automatically search for the best
channel to use and use that instead of
something that you might configure
manually. This automatic configuration
will also help if someone turns on
another access point nearby. Your access
point will recognize that additional
frequencies are in use and it will
adjust to find the best frequencies for
your particular network.
In many of these SOHO routers, you'll
notice that a guest login may be enabled
by default. This is usually provided for
convenience so that anyone can plug in
this access point and immediately have
multiple people connecting to the
network. But from a security
perspective, you probably don't want
anyone being able to connect to your
local wireless network. But you could
add some additional security and use the
guest network for other devices such as
an internet of things network or a lab
network. This would allow you to keep
those devices off of your main network,
but still provide those devices with
access to the internet. And regardless
of what you're implementing, you should
always enable security on these
networks. For a network at home or a
network at your company, you should at a
minimum be using WPA2 and ideally WPA3.
As a security professional, when I walk
into a conference room, I'm looking
around immediately to see what jacks
might be available in the wall for me to
plug into. You'll often see these in
break rooms or open areas where there's
an RJ45 jack in the wall that connects
to a set of switches in the main closet.
A good security best practice is to
disable any interfaces where something
is not currently connected. That way, I
can't walk into your conference room,
plug into your RJ45 connection, and
immediately have access to all of the
devices on your local network. You could
even take this a step further and enable
802.1x
on these networks. We often refer to
this as network access control. With
802.1x, you're presented with a login
screen before you're able to connect to
the network. This is a very common
configuration on wireless networks, but
you can also apply 802.1x to wired
networks as well. In the network
configuration of your SOHO router, you
might see an option for port forwarding.
This is a way for you to allow devices
on the internet to gain access to
services that are on the inside of your
network. For example, you could turn on
a web server on the inside of your
network, create a port forwarding rule,
and now anyone on the internet would be
able to traverse your firewall to gain
access to that web server. There's
usually three or four pieces of
information that are required to create
a port forward. One would be a private
IP address. So, in our example, this
would be the IP address that we're using
internally for our web server. Then, we
would have a port number that you would
access publicly. that's on the outside
of the firewall and then you would have
a port number that is used to
communicate internally to that web
server. Sometimes these are the same
port number but you could also make
these different port numbers as well. On
larger enterprise devices we refer to
this as a destinationnat or a statnat.
This is translating or converting a
public IP address to a private IP
address on the inside of your network.
Another important consideration is when
you create a port forward, that port
forward is always available 24 hours a
day, 7 days a week. That's different
than universal plug-andplay where the
port forward may only be active while
the application is running and when you
close the application, the port forward
is automatically disabled. With a
statically configured port forward in
your firewall, that access is available
always.
So, here is our SOHO router and it's
connected to a couple of switches. And
you can see on our internal network, we
have our internal web server. There's a
laptop and other devices that are on the
network as well. We would like to give
people on the internet access to the web
server that's on the inside of our
network, but people on the internet are
not able to connect to a private IP
address that's inside of our firewall.
Instead, we're going to create a port
forward configuration that says if
anybody connects to our public IP
address, which is 66.20.14,
translate that IP address to
192.168.3.22.
You can see that's the IP address of our
internal web server. So, a user on the
internet will communicate directly to
66.20.14.
Once that reaches our router or
firewall, that device will look at the
conversion table and see that anything
inbound to 66.20.114
should be translated to 192.168.3.22.
It performs the translation inside of
that device and sends the traffic to the
internal web server. A port forward is
going to open up holes in your firewall
and make your network less secure. This
may or may not be the objective that
you're looking for. So, make sure that
you know exactly what you'd like to
configure in the port forward and that
you're using the appropriate security
for this connection.